hey youtubers this Charlie this week on
Doctor Who we got to see the Daleks
again for the first time since Peter
Capaldi became the doctor so I wanted to
do a bonus video for my favorite first
appearances of monsters things basically
the first time the show used certain
things this year is all about correcting
mistakes of the past so we will be
revisiting a lot of classics a good
example is coal Hill School - basically
made the introduction of Danny pink and
Clara similar to the way the series
introduced Barbara Wright and Ian
Chesterton whatever we saw coal Hill
School during unearthly child so this
will be my top five introductions my QA
video is gonna post tonight or tomorrow
morning depend on which time zone you
live in which means there's still plenty
of time to enter my giveaway but
starting off with number five the first
doctor lies the doctor didn't start
quoting the infamous rules till the
fourth doctor's run but one of the first
instances of the doctor lies was during
an earthly child technically during cave
of the skulls which was part of that
first serial the way they organized
stories back then was really different
so there were a lot of different stories
inside each serial while visiting
prehistoric times the doctor is a costed
by cave man who claims he saw him make
fire but when asked to reproduce it in
front of everyone he finds he's
forgotten his matches inside the TARDIS
one of the cavemen cries liar so
strictly speaking it's not like a doctor
lies moment but it's all about broken
promises broken trust which is something
that's gonna be really important for
series eight the cave man who found the
doctor trusted him to help him and the
doctor failed to produce when he was put
on the spot Moffitt's really did about
taking bits and themes from the past and
weaving them into news stories since
there are so many first article
references in these first two episodes
and Capaldi is correcting mistakes of
the past I wonder if we're gonna
continue to see trust issues come up the
doctor wants to be good man but his own
nature usually gets the better of him
like when they were inside the Dalek and
he stopped for a moment it just marveled
at the idea of a good Dalek and
completely changed the mission to
explore this crazy new thing unfolding
in front of his eyebrows the first time
rule number one was quoted it was do
exactly as I say the rules have changed
a bunch of times but I feel like my
favorite rule number ones are don't
wander off in the doctor
but on to number four the TARDIS acts as
its own character for the first time the
best most recent example is during
doctor's wife when the TARDIS literally
becomes a person for a brief period but
the first time it acted like a character
on the show was during the first
doctor's run in the third serial edge of
destruction during the events of the
previous sequel as they escapes Karl the
doctor hit the fast return switch on the
TARDIS it got stuck and they basically
started hurling to the beginning of the
universe I should say the beginning of
time but it meant the TARDIS destruction
so as a way to warn the doctor in his
companions the TARDIS started behaving
really erratically so the story is all
about people trying to communicate with
the TARDIS figure out what's wrong and
fix it before everyone dies of all the
messy theories I think one of my
favorites is definitely the idea that
she is the personification of a TARDIS
just because of what it would mean for
the story of series 8 I think she'll end
up being someone much more sinister than
the TARDIS or at least the doctors
TARDIS just because during doctor's wife
it seemed like it was much more of a
benevolent motherly force like it had a
loving relationship with the doctor
Missy on the other hand seems much more
like a brainwashed melody pond on
another level edge of destruction as a
TV story was a big deal because it was a
team bonding episode for Ian Chesterton
Barbara Wright Susan and the doctor it
makes me feel like we'll see something
similar whenever Danny pink boards the
TARDIS there'll be some crisis the Danny
Carr and the doctor will work together
to solve and they'll all start trusting
each other more as a result but on to
number 3 the Dalek invasion of Earth
this was one of the first big instances
of the series bringing the space battle
down to earth previously Earth had
always been treated fairly nicely you
know the Companions had been whisked
away by the doctor Peter Pan style but
this time the battle came back to earth
even though it was a future version of
Earth they actually recreated this scene
during Marcus's adventure and time and
space so if you actually want to watch
that in a historical context just watch
that special again the episode was also
the first time the Daleks used the
battle cry exterminate they had been
saying exterminated before this but
exterminate would obviously go on to
become the really famous line it was
also one of the first instances of a
companion leaving the doctor Susan
basically gets left behind on that
future earth in the context of the story
she falls in love with a freedom fighter
and rather than make her choose between
him and her new
love the doctor just locks her out of
the TARDIS and leaves the doctor lies
and the doctor leaves people behind I
know there's a lot of rumors about clara
leaving in the christmas special
we can talk more about that as we get
closer to the series a finale just
because i don't feel like we have enough
information yet but if you remember in
some of my earlier bonus videos i talked
about how the series 8 finale is gonna
pay homage to another big invasion from
the second doctor's run but on to number
two the first appearance of the master
johnson was my first master but for a
lot of the fandom Roger Delgado is still
the biggest version of the character
just like Tom Baker is the most famous
doctor but the character of the master
was first written into the series during
the Third Doctor's run and Terra the
Autons there were a lot of other stories
in the audio dramas and the comics and
the novels that explain what the master
was doing before to tear the Autons and
they did a pretty good job of retconning
him into the doctors history I know a
lot of you guys want to see the
character come back in series 8 and
there are a lot of Missy mistress
theories based on Moffitt's comments
about the master like the male master
being gone and the fact that Missy seems
to have Time Lord like abilities I like
the way that later stories introduce the
idea that the Time Lords use the master
as a device to keep the doctor busy as
if they played the characters against
each other everyone has their favorite
Doctor Who villain but for me the master
is the doctors Moriarty he'll always be
his best villain all the Danny pink
Watson references kind of make me wonder
if Moffitt's doing the Missy mistress
thing is part of a larger Sherlock theme
in series 8 it might just be a
coincidence but I love the idea that
Moffat would try to slip a wholock
crossover past us without anyone
realizing it
maybe that's what all those equations
are for the key to the Doctor Who
universe crossing over with the Benedict
Cumberbatch's Sherlock universe it would
take some amazing math to get those two
universes to cross over inside the Canon
but my number 1 doctor who first the
first appearance of Gallifrey it was
during the second doctor's run in
wargames basically his final story the
doctor had to stop an alien race from
creating a super army to conquer the
galaxy the doctor asked the Time Lords
for help but in doing so submits himself
to sanctions for stealing the TARDIS
during his first incarnation the planet
is not called Gallifrey but it's the
first time we see the doctor's home it's
the first time we visit Gallifrey part
of series 8 is taking the long way
around to the pocket universe where
Gallifrey is located and I'm
sure some of you have seen the spoilery
images from the finale but if you want
to comment on any possible connections
just be sure to use spoiler tags in the
comments it's totally possible that this
final second Doctor story could be part
of what the series 8 finale is Gallifrey
is a destination is rumoured to play a
role in series 8 but we don't know how
or when so I'm wondering if Capaldi or
Clara will ask them for help again like
she did during the Christmas special but
they'll extract a price it's possible
she could be collateral damage in the
conflict of the finale and the Missy
story that is unless Missy is a future
version of Clara which is another great
theory but that would just make things
so much more complicated but now it's
your turn let me know in the comments
what are your favorite Doctor Who first
moments like the first time the show
introduced a monster are used to
catchphrase any time the show did
something for the first time in related
news my Q&A is gonna post later tonight
or tomorrow depending on which time zone
you live in the giveaway for this week
will be open until I make that video
remember all you have to do to enter my
series 8 weekly giveaways is just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
videos since next week is robot of
Sherwood I might make my next bonus
video about my favorite fictional
characters in Doctor Who history like
whenever the show took a fantasy
character from a book and made them a
character on the show but totally feel
free to leave me suggestions for future
bonus video topics normally my bonus
videos will post before episodes there
too I'm still moving so my schedule is
like a little bit wonky right now but in
the meantime click here to get the Q&A
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and click here to get my episode
2 review thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you